ich war mal wieder im internet unterwegs
und hab dann so ein artikel in dirty
architekt zu halloween job im stil fällt
das ist also ein beitrag über 30
architekten die eine gewisse aufgabe zu
erfüllen hatten und die komplett
verkauft haben und dabei waren natürlich
auch bilder hier haben wir
beispielsweise das erste bild und auf
den ersten blick denkt man vielleicht
erst mal so ok links ist so eine treppe
da kann man ganz normal herlaufen und
rechts ist halt für leute im rollstuhl
ich meine bei so einer treppe die
vielleicht so zwei drei stufen hat kann
man es da noch machen dass man dann eben
eine schräge platziert wo leute im
rollstuhl runterfahren können aber doch
nicht bei katyn 40 stufen
das ist einfach nur noch extrem sport
für leute im rollstuhl im nächsten bild
brauche ich gar keinen großen kommentar
mehr abgeben und zwar war das dann
irgend einer schule ich hoffe das war
keine designschule natürlich braucht man
wenn man die statik bei sowas
berücksichtigt natürlich auch säulen die
das stockwerk obendrüber quasi halten
das haben die allerdings mitten in den
gang gesetzt
ich glaube da
nichts mehr zu sagen das hier ist
eigentlich auf den ersten blick ein ganz
normaler eingangsbereich wo unten
sondern schiebetür ist unten links der
rezeption immer dann allerdings das
komplette bild betrachtet sich das ganze
so aus also wenn man will kann man oben
auch noch chillen die frage ist halt nur
wie man dahin kommt er ist keine leiter
der ist kein weg da ist keine tür keine
jedenfalls sehr gut
der architekt soll das mal vor ihr seid
irgendwie einem gebäude oder irgendwie
einem treppenhaus oder in einem parkhaus
oder irgendwo und auf einmal bricht ein
feuer aus und ihr denkt euch ok wo ist
der nächste hydrant dass sich das
irgendwie löschen kann oder so hinter
dem geländer schraube ich erst mal das
gelände ab dann hole ich mir den
hydranten raus und dann ist ja schon
alles abgebrannt hat sich auch stufen
fahrt war habe ich in bulgarien geld
abgehoben und der automat war enorm weit
unten das heißt ich musste mich quasi so
mehr oder weniger so ein bisschen bücken
damit ich überhaupt geld abheben konnte
und irgendwie meine pin code eingeben
konnte diese frau musste treppen hoch
laufen um überhaupt an den automaten
ranzukommen
ich habe übrigens noch ein bankautomat
bild leute wer kommt auf sonne idee soll
dann nur weil geld abheben können oder
was ist nächste bild wurde aufgenommen
von einem typen der auf einer hausparty
war bei seinen kollegen und er wollte in
den keller gehen und dann hat er das
vorgefunden
es gibt einen keller klar da ist ja auch
eine tür allerdings wo führt die treppe
hin
irgendwo gegen eine wand
den stadion geht um beispielsweise
football guckt oder rugby oder fußball
oder was weiß ich auch immer dann wählt
man ja natürlich ein platz aus wo man
irgendwie am besten sehen kann da gibt
es daher gute plätze wo man relativ nach
unten am geschehenen sitzt oder hall
plätze wo man eher nicht so gut sieht
ein bisschen entfernt ist und relativ
weit oben sitzt oder es gibt halt plätze
wo man direkt gegen die wand guckt
eigentlich ist ein gullydeckel immer
tiefer als die straße so dass das wasser
da rhein fließt aber irgendwie hat der
ist hier irgendwie höher gesetzt
deswegen ist es steht alles unter wasser
jetzt immer wieder beim statikprobleme
angekommen und warten wir heute schon
als zweites bild das von dieser schule
wo diese sollen quasi direkt in den weg
gebaut wurden ich glaube da brauche ich
nichts mehr zu sagen da kann man ja noch
irgendwie dran vorbei gehen oder drüber
klettern oder was weiß ich machen
allerdings hier wurden die sollen direkt
in die fenster gesetzt also bei allen
sachen konnte ich es vielleicht doch
irgendwie so ein bisschen verstehen aber
das ist einfach nur dumm
ihr kennt das vielleicht von hotels und
zwar habt ihr da wenn ihr das fenster
aufmacht oft noch so ein gitter davor
dass ihr quasi mich raus falt- und die
können die tür dann halt trotzdem
komplett öffnen aber dieses gitter
verhindert euch quasi dass ihr ausfall
hier fällt man trotzdem raus also das
gitter macht tatsächlich überhaupt
keinen sinn bei diesem bau wäre dass wir
die planung der architekten für die
treppe also quasi eine ganz normale
treppen man geht auf der einen seite
hoch wie kurz und die kurve dann geht
man auf der anderen seite wieder hoch so
wurde das ganze dann umgesetzt
you had won job newfield leute die im
rollstuhl sitzen sitzen im rollstuhl
[Musik]
es war wieder eine sehr kluge aussage
luca jedenfalls impliziert das halt dass
sie im rollstuhl sind
damals hielt ich dumm bin ich vielleicht
noch zehn mal sagen wenn jemand im
rollstuhl sitzt ist es für ihn als enorm
schwer irgendwie treppen hoch zu kommen
und ich zeige euch einfach mal hier des
behinderten klo
wer das gebaut hat hast du irgendein
gehirns hält hinter im korb ich mache
das selber beispielsweise echt sehr
häufig wenn ich putze dass ich kein bock
habe ihn wie eine pflanze hoch sehen
sondern nichts staubsauger dann quasi um
die pflanze herum weil ich einfach zu
faul bin hier haben leute ein rohr
verlegt und sich einfach an der uhr
orientiert ist ja nicht so dass man die
uhr einfach abnehmen kann und wo anders
hin hängen kann vielleicht kennt ihr das
wenn man fahrrad fährt und man fährt die
ganze zeit quasi auf der straße und dann
geht der fahrradweg sondern kleine kurve
fährt dann quasi auf dem bürgersteig
weiter irgendwie wollten die das hier
aber irgendwie wollten die das auch
nicht also man muss halt kurzem bunny
hop dann mit dem fahrrad machen wie ihr
seht ihr nun ein bild eingeblendet von
einem wunderschönen balkon also der ist
echt schön da ist so ein schiebefenster
man kann auf den balkon gehen und
darunter befindet sich noch ein balkon
der sieht allerdings so aus da kann man
einfach nicht drauf gehen kommen nun
auch schon zum letzten bild und zwar
fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich was ist
falsch an diesem bild
naja es ist eigentlich ein ganz normales
bauwerk ist sieht nur aus eine fucking
toilette
wer kommt auf so eine idee das was ihr
vom video meine damen und herren wenn es
euch gefallen und las man fetten leiter
und weil 73.000 likes
weil ich mit meinem stuhl nach hinten
egal was mache ich eigentlich
ach so erfolgt nur auf instagram
instagram da kommst lukas